"THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN FACING CALLS
FROM THE MEDIA TO QUIT BEFORE HE
DOES MORE DAMAGE TO THE COUNTRY
AND HIS PARTY.
AND AS BIDEN RECOVERS FROM
COVID, A GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO
HIT THE GUY WHEN HE HAS DOWN AND
SOME ABETTOR TO REPLACE HIM.
AND BOY, BIDEN IS DOWN DAMPIER
THE LATEST QUINNIPIAC POLL AN
ALL-TIME LOW 31%.
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
GIVING THE GREEN LIGHT TO THIS.
QUIT JOE, QUIT!
AND SAVE THE MIDTERMS WITH A ONE
TERM PLEDGE.
CHRIS CHRISTIE SUMMING UP THE
PRESIDENT'S SITUATION THIS WAY
PARENTS BECAUSE THERE WERE 54%
OF YOUR OWN PARTY SAID THE YEAR
AND A HALF INTO THE PRESIDENCY
THANKS BUT NO THANKS.
THAT DOES REFLECT, I AGREE WITH
YOU, THE FRUSTRATION OF
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE SOME DON'T
THINK HE'S DONE ENOUGH AND SOME
BECAUSE THEY THINK HE'S DONE TOO
MUCH.
JOE BIDEN IS IN NO-MAN'S-LAND.
THAT IS AN AWFUL PLACE TO BE AS
AN OFFICE HOLDER WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY.
>> Jesse: AS THE PRESIDENT
FINDS HIMSELF IN A MORE
POLITICAL PERIL, HE IS RUNNING
OUT OF ALLIES.
HIS CHIEF OF STAFF RON KLAIN
WITH A LAME EXPLANATION FOR THE
POLES.
>> IT IS A REFLECTION HOW PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THE COUNTRY.
SOME THINGS IN THE COUNTRY
AREN'T GOING WELL, NOT BECAUSE
OF WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID BUT,
IN FACT, WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING AGAINST.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, BEFORE I
ASK YOU, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THE MSNBC HOST OUTFIT?
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU ARE
ASKING ME?
>> Jesse: I AM.
I'M NOT ASKING GREG.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WANT TO
COMMENT ON MY OUTFIT TOO.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I THINK
ABOUT RON KLAIN THOUGH.
WHEN A GUY SAYS WE ARE NOT
DISAPPOINTED IN JOE BIDEN.
OKAY, IT'S NOT JOE.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
WHAT IS IT, 71% OF THE AMERICANS
DON'T WANT THIS GUY TO RUN AGAIN
AND HE'S A YEAR AND A HALF INTO
HIS PRESIDENCY?
I MEAN, YOU CAN TRY TO SPIN IT
ANYWAY YOU WANT.
YOU CAN TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DON'T BELIEVE YOUR LYING EYES.
IT IS BETTER THAN YOU THINK IT
IS.
THE TRUTH IS WHEN YOU GO TO BUY
GAS, WHEN YOU GO TO THE
SUPERMARKET, WHEN YOU GO TO BUY
BABY FORMULA, WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE AFGHANISTAN.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE NEIGHBOR
WHO HAS A DRUNK PROBLEM AND YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON
COMING TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND THE WORD FENTANYL HAS NEVER
COME OUT OF JOE BIDEN'S
MOUTH, THIS GUY IS TOTALLY
CLUELESS TO WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND SO, YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY CAN
TRY TO COVER IT UP AND SUGARCOAT
ANYWHERE THEY WANT.
AMERICANS KNOW HOW THEY FEEL.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY SEE, AND
THEY GOT IT RIGHT.
>> Jesse: CHRISTIE'S
INTERPRETATION OF BEING A NO
MAN'S LAND, GREG AND NOBODY
LIKES HIM BECAUSE HE'S DONE TOO
MUCH.
>> Greg: THIS IS A MISTAKE TO
FRAME IT THIS WAY BECAUSE IF YOU
ARE SAYING THE LEFT HATES YOU
AND THE MODERATES ATE YOU, THAT
COULD BE A COMPLEMENT FOR
DEMOCRATS, YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING?
YOU ARE AN EQUAL OPPORTUNIST
WHEN IT COMES TO DISCIPLINING
PEOPLE.
BUT IT COULD BE THAT HE IS
REALLY BAD.
YOU KNOW, IF BIDEN -- THE MARK
OF A GOOD MUDDY IS YOU KNOW IT
IS A GOOD MOVIE OF THE FIRST
10 MINUTES.
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY YOU SIT
DOWN IN 10 MINUTES, OH, MY GOD,
THIS IS NOT WHAT WE EXPECTED.
YOU CAN LEAVE THE MOVIE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T LEAVE THIS
MOVIE.
YOU ARE STUCK HERE BUT THE MORE
THE DEMS TONIGHT BIDEN, THE MORE
HE SHOULD GET FOUR MORE YEARS.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT IS WHAT THE
DEMS DO WITH REPUBLICANS.
THEY SEES THE MOST VULNERABLE
CANDIDATES AND TRY TO DIG THEM
UP OR WHATEVER YOU CALL IT AN
EGG THEM ON.
THEY SHOULD WANT TO RUN AGAINST
BIDEN.
BUT THE DISCONTENT, THE
DISCONTENT IS GETTING LOUDER
BECAUSE JANUARY 6TH.
IT ENDED UP ACCIDENTALLY
EXONERATING TRUMP.
NO CRIMINALITY TO MOVE THE
GOALPOST INTO THE PARKING LOT.
NO, HE TOOK TOO LONG.
WHY IS IT THAT HE SEEMS MORE
ELECTABLE NOW?
IS IT BECAUSE THE PUBLIC SAW IT
WAS A SHOW TRIAL AND THEY DIDN'T
SYMPATHIZE?
THEY ACTUALLY SYMPATHIZED WITH
THE OTHER SIDE AND CONGRESS,
THEY SAW AS DRAMA QUEENS?
THIS IS A TEACHABLE MOMENT.
TRUMP LOOKS BETTER THAN BIDEN
AFTER THREE WEEKS OF NONSTOP
POLITICAL ACTION PROP, THEN THAT
SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR
CANDIDATE.
THE GUY IS LESS POPULAR THAN
CHRONIC HALITOSIS, HE STINKS.
>> Jesse: JESSICA, TO GREG'S
POINT ABOUT THE MOVIE ONSET,
USUALLY PRESIDENCIES HAVE PEAKS
AND VALUES.
TRUMP'S WAS LIKE THAT.
HE WOULD KILL A BIG TERRORISTS.
HE WOULD BE A PEACH AND THEN
ACQUITTED.
>> Jessica: AGAIN.
FINALLY.
>> Greg: AND NOT EVEN THIRD
ACT YET.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN SINCE HE
HAS COME AND HE HAS GONE DOWN,
DOWN FURTHER AND FURTHER
AFGHANISTAN, THE BORDER AND HE
GETS OVER THEM POLES OFF OF HIS
BIKE.
AND EVERYTHING HAS GONE DOWN.
HAS HE DONE ANYTHING WELL SO
FAR.
>> Jessica: DEMOCRATS ARE MOST
UPSET ABOUT FALLING OFF OF THE
BIKE.
THIS GUY HAS GOT TO GO.
>> Jesse: SYMBOLIC.
>> Greg: NOMEX BEFORE CAN I
GET THE GEORGIA PEACH COVID
DENIER AND THE GUYS BACKING OFF?
A LOT OF POINTS WERE MADE AND I
WANT TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT.
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE THOUGHT A
SHOW TRIAL AND
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
THE UNELECTABLE AGAIN AND
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
HE SAID BY AND WATCH THIS FOR
HOURS AND SO UNPREDICTABLE.
>> Greg: HE WAS ABOUT FINDING
SOME CRIMINAL RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT'S RIGHT, THAT WILL HAPPEN
IN SEPTEMBER, RIGHT?
>> Jessica: THERE ARE
CONSERVATIVES WHO ARE ARGUING
THAT THEY HAVE -- ANYWAY.
>> Greg: THEY ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE.
>> Jessica: JOE BIDEN IS VERY
UNPOPULAR.
RON KLAIN, YOU CAN SAY HIS POLL
NUMBERS ARE BAD AND THAT IS FINE
BECAUSE THAT IS GOOD NEWS,
DEMOCRATS LOOKING AT THE
CONGRESSIONAL BALLOT ARE INCHING
UP AND UP AND UP.
AND NOW IT IS NOT A WAVE
ELECTION BUT COMPETITIVE
ELECTION.
>> Jesse: IT IS?
BEFORE AND OUR FOX PULLING.
SOME OF THE BEST POLLSTERS ARE
HERE AT FOX, THEY HAVE ALL
SHIFTED THEIR ANALOGY WITH
G.O.P. POLLS THAT CAME OUT IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
ECHELON, THEY ALL HAD DEMOCRATS
UP 3% TO 5%.
I AM SAYING WE DON'T LOSE THE
HOUSE, BUT CERTAINLY A CHANCE
WHEN WE USE A FEW SEATS.
I THINK THE BOTTOM READING, THE
FOX READING FROM THE POSTERIORS
HERE.
AND KEEPING THE SENATE.
THAT IS A GREAT OUTCOME FOR
MIDTERMS.
>> Jesse: LOOK, YOU WANT TO
PUT SOME MONEY ON THAT?
>> Jessica: HOW MUCH?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: $100.
>> Greg: HOW ABOUT THE LOSER
HAS TO HAVE THE KID BABY SIT BY
ME, HOW IS THAT?
>> Jessica: TAKE IT BACK, TAKE
IT BACK.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO GET RID
OF JOE BIDEN IN 2024 BECAUSE
THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE AGAINST
ANY PRESIDENT, ESPECIALLY
DONALD TRUMP IF HE RUNS
PURE JOE BIDEN IS LESS
POPULAR NOW THAN PRESIDENT TRUMS
NOWHERE TO GO FROM HERE.
A LAME DUCK PRESIDENT AND HIS
AGENDA DEAD FOR THE MIDTERMS.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE OFFERING
IS NOT SOMEONE LIKE JOE MANCHIN,
LIKE BIDEN IN 2024 WHO IS A MORE
MODERATE, EFFECTIVE PART OF THE
COUNTRY AND AS AN AMERICAN.
THEY WANT SOMEONE LIKE
GAVIN NEWSOM WHO WAS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WHEN JOE BIDEN
OVERSEAS AND HE STUCK RIGHT IN
THERE TO HAVE A MEETING WITH RON
KLAIN.
EVERYTHING WAS FINE AND NO OTHER
AGENDA OTHER THAN WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
MORE MODERATE THAN JOE BIDEN.
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
EVEN FURTHER TO THE LEFT.
IF THEY WERE SMART, WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN JOE BIDEN AND WHAT
REPUBLICANS DO IN THE HOUSE OR
SENATE, THEY WOULD WORK WITH HIM
LIKE BILL CLINTON DID.
HE COULD REVIVE HIS PRESIDENCY
AFTER REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER,
GIVEN THE WAY RON KLAIN HAS ON
THE LEFT, I DOUBT THAT WILL
HAPPEN.
THE OTHER THING IS, THEY ARE
REDEFINING THE WORD RECESSION.
I MEAN LIKE THEY CAN REDEFINE
WORDS AND SAY IT DOESN'T EXIST.
EVERY AMERICAN KNOWS THAT WE ARE
IN A RECESSION PURE THEY ARE ALL
SAVING MONEY FOR A RECESSION.
80%, 90% IS AFFECTED BY HIGH GAS
PRICES WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING ON PURPOSE.
THE IDEA WELL IT DOESN'T
TECHNICALLY MEAN THIS, THEY WERE
COMPLETELY OUT OF TOUCH OF WHAT
PEOPLE ARE FEELING AND
REDEFINING THE WORD AND NOT
MENTIONING IT IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE EVERYONE STATUS WITH THE
ECONOMY.
AND CLEARLY, NO POLICY POSITION
THEY WILL C